hi everyone my name is erica cameron and
i'm with the ibm cloud team
in this video we're going to show you
how you can run an application with ibm
cloud code engine
starting with your source code instead
of a container image
from the code engine overview page we're
going to choose run your source code
you'll see that it's pre-populated with
the url to a github repo
which in this case is the home to a set
of sample workloads
that we used to demonstrate code engine
let's use that and click start creating
to move on to the
next step on this page we can give some
more information
or configuration options about our
application
to keep it simple we're just going to
use the defaults for everything with one
exception
in the build details section we need to
provide it with a bit more details about
how to build our image
from the source code let's click the
specify build details button
here we can modify any details about the
source that we need to change
in this case we're going to continue to
use those default values
meaning the get branch is called master
and the directory in the repository to
find the source code is hello
let's click next to keep going
on this next panel we can tell code
engine how we want to build the image
meaning do we have a docker file with
the instructions for how to build it
or should we use cloud native build
packs which automatically know how to
convert source code in many popular
languages
into container images again we're going
to keep with the defaults
and use the docker file that's in the
hello directory in the repository
so let's keep going by clicking next
again
on this panel we can tell code engine
where to store that image that's going
to be built
notice that you can choose which
container registry to use
in this case it already knows about
ibm's container registry
so we'll just use that then we'll tell
it what namespace to use
this is like a folder in the registry so
we can group these related images
together
we'll use the first one in this list
called ce demo
and finally we'll give it a name we can
either choose the name of an existing
image
and override it or give it a new name
we'll give this one a new name called
hello
and with that we can click next and also
hit create
notice that the status indicates that
we're doing a build first
before the actual deployment of the
application
from our other video about managing
applications this screen probably looks
pretty familiar to you
it's the main configuration page for our
application and all the same options are
available to you
the key thing about this flow is that
only the input
into the deployment has changed meaning
we're starting with the source code
instead of with an image
beyond that difference everything's the
same with how with the respect of how
you manage the application
now that the build and deploy are done
as we can see from the ready status
let's verify that it's there by clicking
the application url button
and you can see that it's just a simple
hello world app and it's been deployed
to the internet
so before we wrap this up it's important
to note that while we deployed
an application the exact same process
could have been used to deploy a batch
job the video about jobs started with an
image so we could also have started with
that workflow with the source code as
well
just like we did here the choice is
yours
that's all the time we have for today
but hopefully you found this quick
walkthrough of how to deploy workloads
into code engine
from source code pretty exciting and i
encourage you to look at our other
videos to see more of these
code engine features and of course
we hope that you'll go visit the code
engine webpage on ibm.com
to play with it yourself thank you